only thing it is bad I had a rough life
I lived in the neighborhood where there
was no pity for the weak
you couldn't smile and you didn't have
no sympathy you have no remorse if he
got in a way and he did he did the wrong
thing you broke his ass off and you left
him away yet ain't no going back to
clean him up you know you bleeding this
[ __ ] you know I had a homie that was
kicking it with me over here and they
were and uh he had to do it in the face
with a bottle and man do you know what
what it feels like to get in and face
with a glass glass bottle and then the
skin just tear and you looking at him
like what do you do I need my [ __ ]
right here I got wrong with them because
if I can roll with them I'll be one of
them dudes get me it with the [ __ ]
bottle too so I won't thing that really
just say [ __ ] I'm alive I'm with
child [ __ ]
refreshes a mother you know when you
don't have nobody with you dog that's
just the way it is you know I mean I
could ask the homie don't why do you
doing something like that and he
probably jumped in my ass man sorry I
hate trigger but you got people
I got some blue homies man they did a
little dry part right I'm sitting at the
county jail I've been in for robbery
right now then he come in for a drive-by
I say done whatever we went over though
you wouldn't did our thing I say McLaren
she was drunk make it you know told he's
chased out y'all ran a car polis up
thinking what happened he said oh we we
bust on these [ __ ] and the police is
coming around the corner has me was
busted and that's how he got upon us
stuff and so I try to punch in this [ __ ]
not try to punch it all the way back to
the hood and snow then I read man so did
you shoot - do you know where he shot to
do that she started doing in a damn leg
do you get recognition when I do you
gotta think on the back for that that
was like him don't you where'd you shoot
him in my shotty been allayed you know
what kind of gun you a 380
he had small good small bullets
small car
and I don't love guys to get away from
the one time so you got caught so as you
do coming to court
yo yeah you come to court to testify
against make it so call you believe me
or not
usually when you shoot a person above
the waist just when you raise their some
time they gave my lonely life shooting
I got my [ __ ] ass I read
muffled call walked up and knocked that
[ __ ] down that's how you go you gonna
go do some dumb [ __ ] you know but
somewhere along the line somebody gotta
be the smart man
and wake up and recognize reality and
know what's real man I got another homie
let me tell you that thought they was
going up going to do a drive-by and they
went in this apartment building into a
bunch of bombs in these apartments and
blew up kids and we started them getting
the death penalty they took the life
without with no possibility of parole
so the neighborhood I come from it's
been always been a tough neighborhood to
living and they're just not the
neighborhood itself it's the people's
cause the neighborhood don't make it bad
mr. beetroots that's there that make it
bad
hell I didn't be placed in positions
where I may go get the gun dog we finna
go do sir
and if I man I don't want to roll with
that [ __ ] what you mean you don't wanna
roll with that [ __ ] you rollin [ __ ]
you ain't down what is it it's up no man
but you might well tell them up well I'm
sick I got the flu man I can't go right
now
Nicky but you gotta get you ass on out
here man come on
all right dog I got you I got you I'm
coming so when you what will get sitting
like that the peoples that ain't been up
and a lot of these dudes down here you
see now you they come from nice homes
nice family good background farm
education that that helped me get
certain things that they needed in order
to go to the next step of college or
whatever you know I didn't get that
chance dog because we didn't have enough
the push of pushing ahead maybe I should
have been smart enough when I got a
little old but I was already in
concentrating I was already adapted to
the negativity that makes you a bad
person in society
I don't want to call myself any bad
person now because I think that
everybody deserves the chance to see
what's real and what's not real and if I
can go back in time the end the job I
would do the right thing because I know
it's a lot more opportunities out there
a lot more things that could have had
that could have been at my favorite why
cause it did better and where I could
have had my own home
maybe even a little small business I
don't know but I could have had a lot
more lady in my position try to took the
time out stayed in school and listened
to my mother but some of the bad things
that I learned was push for my mother
because she was like why you ain't
around these little boys why don't you
go around some people yeah I told her
that she had the [ __ ] of death that
that's my age they gangs and stuffing
with games and so she was like well why
don't you hang with Eric and Michael no
[ __ ] I did when we went to school we was
at the school and then nigga's let the
[ __ ] come up to school to take our
[ __ ] I'm gonna be with those [ __ ] that
scared I want to be with somebody that
ain't gonna take nobody's [ __ ] so
that's why I made the decision the way I
made it was wrong and I could shine in
my mother's eyes because she only wanted
the best things for me but she didn't
know what I had to deal with when it was
time to go to school
when it was time to walk the street when
it was time to hang out she didn't know
nothing about that
cuz she was too busy sitting in the
house drinking or doing our own thing
so I made my decisions for myself and I
had three younger brothers that was
younger than me that I needed to show
support to so if they had probably I
want to let them know that come get me
and I'll stand up for you though I'll
fight for you and I remember my little
brother playing his day you had a
problem what they would do and he come
get me say a as we sneak over tripping
over your stuff
and I said I got you come on let's go
right let this [ __ ] know right now
leave him not to you know mess with you
and he boat [ __ ] then I went around
there he came he got his brother he went
got his brother there dude I'm from the
fight knock when he got my brother I
told him look how do we do it still
gonna be cool
I'd knock that [ __ ] my little brother
he was happy but it made us move now to
where we thought we was hard cause now
you know I mean in thinking good again
again I just want to say man
I have to seeing all the things I did in
life I would want something better than
without what I lived on that stage right
there because it didn't give me nothing
now I'm up an agent I have nothing I'm
just trying to be peaceful now I still
carry the gang activity when it's
necessary and I'm a gang affiliated
because I come from an area where that's
all I knew that's all I know
that's all I stand by saw a lot H of my
grade it is what it is I won't count the
number I just rolled with it
you